this is very exciting we are at Saint
Joseph's Medical Center because today
Andy Dwyer is getting his casts off it
is a great day for Andy and it's a
wonderful day for my subcommittee oh my
god your boobs are dead stop it no
they're not I'm calling it Tyla boob
death 9:18 a.m. we did everything we
could but they were just too small okay
and how do you feel I feel good I'm
recording some of these sound bites for
the website so I need you to say
something a little bit more moving and
poignant you know pithy articulate kind
of grabby
but unrehearsed like you just made that
but think about it for a second now say
it's only that and then be funny okay go
how do you feel I'm happy that's great
if Leslie had a boyfriend and he broke
his legs I would do the same for her I'd
probably bring fewer stuffed animals
though Wow it's like a sweaty pinata oh
yeah my pirate doctor if I may could I
keep that cast please it's a highly
disgusting request I don't see why not
thank you this is a symbol of new
beginnings a symbol of hope and of our
project we will build this park it is
gonna feel so good to walk again they
might be a little weak at first come to
a stupid boy friends band hey dr. Harris
um
Annie's playing show tonight and we'd
love it if you came by I think there's
gonna be a good turnout at Hannah show
tonight he wrote this new song about
what happened to him called the pit it's
one of those rare songs that rocks
really hard and also informs people
about a small public works project
Sandy's doing well yeah he's a little
shaky still but that's to be expected
well not really
and his cast removed two weeks ago the
muscles wouldn't attribute so much I'm
sorry two weeks ago it's been they were
scheduled to come off but he told me
that you told him he should wait no you
rescheduled he said it was personal that
he'd explained later but then he never
explained I have waited on him hand and
foot for two months well I guess that
explains it hello I am Hey
my early nope you are right on time I
like your costume
oh thanks Raggedy Ann it's one of my
favorite books and I was a kid I'm a
pirate
great oh hey dr. Harris how are you
thanks um this is Ron Swanson from the
Parks Department I know him from that
thing that I'm doing this is dr. Harris
you're a doctor yep
I meant your costume I got it
worlds colliding always awkward
hey bro okay you're under age you're not
hey yeah I'm gonna leave oh okay
this isn't that fun didn't need to tell
me that I got to take this home
nobody was drinking it so I'm gonna take
it I'm gonna take this to meaning to
read it good news is this is just
tendonitis
how is that good news the other option
with shoulder cancer really
no look you exercise a lot here in great
shape little things like this happen
with men of your age men at my age how
old do you think I am 42 huh I am 44 and
I plan to live to be 150 okay so what's
the cure get a time machine and go back
to being 20 dr. Harris you are literally
the meanest person I have ever met you
have two broken bones in your right arm
and four in your hand that's the side
that hurts how soon until he's better
well set the fractures I'd like to keep
him overnight for observation is there
any chance you can fix me in the next
ten minutes sure I'll just advance
medical science 30 years great can mouse
rat play without you they tried once
they're called rat and mouse and they're
awful but you have got to find somebody
there's an old saying show business the
show must go wrong everything always
goes wrong and you just have to deal
with it
okay so now you're sure that everything
is okay you know down there perfectly
Holly that man has the largest penis I
have ever seen I actually don't even
know if he has mumps forgot to look I
was distracted by the largest penis I
have ever seen before you begin a few
ground rules I need you to explain
everything you do before you do it so I
can determine whether I will allow you
oh yeah balsa wood you could at least
use my Hager there's something including
your ear
it's sawdust just blue oh you got strep
throat running your prescription for
penicillin we'll have the rest of your
test results in about 20 minutes
cholesterol I'm interested good day
lease all patients were like that it's
really annoying when they ask questions
Ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually I
take it neat but I will make an
exception in the name of health last
night I watched a movie with Diane and
the girls in which an orange fish is
separated from his father the children
were sniffling which I believed to be
due to the sad nature of the film I was
wrong you have very weak hands why would
you say that just making an observation
for Ben you know the EMT said that if
Lee had sent you his base you could have
lost a thumb I'm totally fine babe
everything is a-okay Coolio beans you
want to meditate real quick no we do not
have time we have a concert to save
excuse me he's feeling better he can go
right in damn it I wonder if I'll ever
stop doing that come on look to the left
all right whatever
are you the kind of doctor who gets
hooked on his own drugs I bet you are so
Andy tell me what happened I was reading
an encyclopedia
and I tripped or fell over and hit my
head or brain helmet you call it yeah he
sneezed and smacked his head against the
wall that sounds about right well if
it's a concussion it's extremely mild so
I wouldn't worry about it anything else
bothering you
nope yeah well I mean yeah I've got a
weird rash in my knee pit area and my
tongue on this side doesn't taste
anything anymore sometimes when I walk
my ankles make like a weird rattlesnake
sound what else things that are far away
from my eyes are fuzzy I once ate a Twix
with the wrapper on it and I've never
seen the wrapper come out also I've
swallowed every piece of gum that I've
treated for the past 25 years I don't
know broke my thumb when the way over
here just fix me well I can help you
with the thumb I don't have to give you
referrals for specialists for the other
thousand things Wow
thanks for nothing dr. Harris you're
welcome okay I got you some magazines
and those boring word jumbles you like
to do is there anything else you need J
maybe some gas tanks I have time how is
he an give it to me straight
he's great he should be out of here in a
day or two doctor medically speaking how
would you describe what happened to
Jerry he had a mild heart attack yeah
but he also exhibited excessive
flatulence is there a term for having a
heart attack while releasing so much gas
not really
gastrointestinal distress is common
during a cardiac event I just want to
hear the doctors say that Jerry had a
fart attack is that too much to ask
thank you so much look at all the
balloons and the flowers in the food and
she's so sweet to come visit this often
well they did cause it Hey no that's
okay I'm glad this happened
me I could do without the mess of
hospital bills but no this was a wake-up
call I'm gonna make some changes I want
at least another 30 years with Gayle and
my girls don't worry Jerry okay you are
gonna have the future that you've always
planned just leave it to us I was up all
night brainstorming and this is the
complete official list of candidates for
Ann's baby daddy Wow how did you come up
with these three names
well I eliminated everyone in a
relationship and the obvious nose like
knuckle hair Dave from HR I don't mind
here I just think he's a dick yeah and I
was left with those three guys don't
forget they don't know about the sperm
donor thing I don't want them to know I
told them I was interviewing them for a
blood here comes the first one dr.
Harris hi there yes and Leslie small
office mine's way bigger it's gonna take
long
got a patient coming in no not at all
please have a seat actually maybe you
should check in on your patient you know
I know that I hate it when my doctor
makes me wait huh that's got a spinal
fracture he's not going anywhere
ooh she's an officer leather
you